[Music]
we wanted to make this pirates of the
carribean I'm really special and really
fresh so we got two new directors
yokomen Essman who are Academy nominated
filmmakers reinvigorate the franchise
with something they've never seen before
there are new characters are gonna bring
a new flavor and a different dimension
to one of the most powerful franchises
of all time when we heard they were
planning on making and other pirates we
chased it we wanted it to feel like a
ride we found on scary and emotional and
that means huge action pieces
we have thousands of extras huge builds
and epic shots with fantastic locations
this film is exciting there's something
huge happening every day so it has an
energy and a force behind it but I've
never really experienced before not only
is it huge in scope but we're dealing
with iconic characters and like homing
ships and elements I felt there was some
sense of magic walking off to the upsets
seeing the craftsmanship in the detail
it's very easy to lose yourself and to
feel like you are in another world
little men tell no tales
[Music]
you